so the rotor ride guys are these cool
guys on YouTube who make really awesome
drone videos Wednesday or Tuesday and
Wednesday the 12th and the 13th of the
week are the two tentative days we have
to film with these guys they are in town
for one week only one week there's about
an hour so before everyone gets in
anything I get to do whatever I want so
I'm going to get my v are grabbing
system working in order to make a game
that I'm thinking of needle to pick
objects up so I'm just going to start by
figuring that it's amazing how easy this
is looks like people think game design
is really hard turns out it's actually
super easy commercials coming along we
made our casting picks on Friday and we
are working with the ad agency to see if
our casting picks aligned with their
branding we pick people that we thought
had good chemistry can sell the beats
correctly on camera but sometimes the
agency wants different looks so the rest
this week will be planning some location
visits rehearsal with the actors and
then shooting on Friday come on well
black alright so they pick it up
oops wrong them hey wait what's going on
now it's like got all this extra it's
like inheriting some sort of motion so I
think there's some sort of like velocity
or something that it's inheriting
because I turn gravity off and I turn
them into basically just like they're
going upwards now I just gone through
basically layered a bunch of animations
they're all parented so they all are
being influenced by their parents motion
this big box I put down first comes out
and rotates everything's stuck to it and
those next-level boxes expand out and
slide in and these other boxes I have
parents those are just inheriting their
motion
and then those come out imagine these
all being modeled nerf guns and you know
be spending a little bit more than two
minutes animating it relatively simple
animation technical doing VFX of YouTube
videos all about the easy techniques
that look nice and get a wow factor and
have impact but don't take days and days
and days to do so wrench of the model
done Plus animation maybe in a day there
you go
picked it up so there's also another
property when you're dealing with
physics objects they're called rigid
bodies you can have them the dynamic
rigid bodies aka bounce wherever the
heck all over the place or be kind of
static or kinematic objects which are
objects that don't actively use the
physics system it's taking the exact
coordinates in my hand and then I'm
turning gravity off for the physics
objects so they don't fall and I'm also
making them kinematics so they just kind
of stop simulating basically two things
if one hand exactly so that's a whole
nother thing I got a code which is
making sure my hand is aware whether
it's holding an object or not these are
a lot of shots so far for darts just in
general at the tert opening we got the
wide shot of it you had the one in the
dirty four and then you have the one of
it closing all takes time yeah this shot
doesn't seem that hard but when you have
six of them it's like yeah they're gonna
take time for sure so you're imagining
like a two guns sort of turret array
just literally animate it in Reverse
basically flush out the whole model
parent all the things together and then
just exactly back down to like a little
sleeve yep ready Ghost Hunters yeah
we're doing practical props for all this
stuff right we're not adding main impose
don't worry about any of that right now
just get the props Niko and I are going
to look at the Sherman Oaks house and
Nick's gonna come with us to the bank so
I can give him some petty cash
so we can go out and get props money oh
yeah
oculus rift is officially out and the
vibe is officially out at the risk of
opening a little bit of a flame war both
headsets have their merits I can see
what people will pick up the oculus I
had to pick between the two to make a
hard call right now I think your life I
got it
I did it I can pick up freakin boxes now
holy [ __ ] and I come throw them or I
can't throw them they don't have them
inheriting velocity yet but check this
out
red box pick it up drop it blue box this
is not set as a pickup object I cannot
pick it up only the red boxes can be
picked up however until bump the blue
boxes because they're all still here
physically one box on top of the other
oops hold on I was a glitch okay well I
glitched it out so I'm not really good
at doing it yet get off in my ass you
know with the ruse I can't I can't be
aggressive in her over a frickin parking
you screamed that's bad
hey I'm normally behind the camera but
I'll make this quick I don't know what
happened
set to go live at 7:00 a.m. something
weird on youtubes end so super sorry
about that and hope you enjoyed the
video